our culture in my mouth you need a
different phrase
what's cooking my name is Chef Elisa
Reynolds executive chef and host of
searching for soul food I am here with
the one and only Lino voice my homie and
of the bear we're about to make soul
food and let's get into it what are we
gonna make I'm hungry all right well
we're gonna make some salmon croquettes
yes some mac and cheese bam and some
yams all right let's do it all right
first we're going to boil the yam so
we're going to pour the yams in here
next we got some brown sugar should I
put this whole Bowl because I would yeah
let's do it we got some cinnamon it's
like Christmas every day when you smell
something yeah it's like a warm hug next
we got a clove yeah we got some vanilla
extract all right then we got some
butter and then we got some neutral oil
just a little bit yeah let's do a little
bit of salt like a speck of salt up in
there a little bit of salt yes okay
and we ready to roll now my mac and
cheese goes like this all right first of
course we're going to start with the
noodles these are gluten-free noodles
and it's just a healthier approach to
mac and cheese we're gonna start the
cheese sauce here with a little milk and
then we're gonna put a little flour in
there put a little butter right here I
have a mixed Jack and cheddar
which is always amazing oh yeah I use
gluten-free
um flour because I just want the whole
recipe to be gluten free now you're on
the bear has that changed your
relationship with food at all it really
gave me more of an appreciation of
understanding what goes into like making
it right like the prep and all the hard
work honestly I would think about like
your restaurant a lot and like days when
I go into like a Sunday when it's
everything's high intensity it's like
you have an understanding of like what
goes into it how long it takes and what
you like sacrifice like the hours and
everything that goes with it it's not
only the love for food but it's for me
it's how people react to it we're gonna
move into our salmon croquettes have you
picked up any kitchen hacks since you've
been uh on the bear a lot of stuff that
I did learn is just like physical it's
like sports in a way it was like you
just learned the Motions of it and you
find your own Groove it's like technique
so you you learn the technique and then
you can flip it to your own you know
what I know I want to see some of your
knife skills it's interesting you to say
that because I spend most of my time
learn how to bake not learning how to
cut now you're doing pretty good what
else are we putting in there oh yeah
what else are we putting we got some
pepper yeah
um seasoning salt the onions just tear
me up and what else Lionel what else
we're cooking with our eyes closed okay
we're gonna put some mayo in there to
kind of that's our binder I think I'm
gonna try it all at the same time all
right and then why don't you add that
for me the mail yep so we got stirring
this up before I throw my eggs in let's
get the oil hot pass me that oil in
I'm you know vegetable oil yeah less
good that's good
nice let's get these eggs in here you
crack one I'll crack one all right
see you do everything right I have to
follow it up with mines oh boom so this
is binding up nicely this represents the
love of our culture when you look at
your plate and you eat it it's history
in that I'm gonna grab my mitts all
right I'm gonna just look at the camera
while she grabs the mix
that
was the worst puppet I've ever seen
oh Holo all right so let's get these
noodles they're ready now we're gonna
get our amazing cheese sauce and we're
gonna mix that in there you can usually
mix it in a mixing bowl you don't have
to go straight to casserole I like to
put raw cheese on top you do the honors
well you just pour it on top and next oh
we get our Croquettes in and then he can
pass it to me yeah they smell like mamas
now let's see what's going on over here
oh those look good oh that smells good
yeah all right so Lionel you're gonna do
this one there
why did you choose these recipes in
these particular dishes these three
honestly I love salmon croquettes and
it's like one of my favorite things when
I was like I remember like one of my
aunts made it when I was a kid and
that's like always stuck with me and
it's like this mac and cheese and yams
it's like it's so full so I was like
it's soul food like you can't you gotta
have those two sides oh well I love that
so we're gonna finish it of course by
putting brown sugar all over the top
well I think everything is ready let's
check it out oh I can smell the hot
sauce it's gonna be good we need a
Dipper all right we're ready to eat this
stuff yes now let's try these candy yams
they look good and probably too sweet
because we both like them extra sweet
yeah oh that looks good mmm it smells
good too
yum you ready for this yeah
Cheers Cheers
[Music]
okay mac and cheese
thanks for watching make sure you check
out the bear and searching for soul food
now streaming on Hulu and season two of
The Bear premieres June 22nd also send
me your favorite soul food recipe with
hashtag soul food Hulu period
[Music]
put some good ass mac and cheese